shame we're talking about shame I feel
shameful plug-in stuff all right dude I
hear you on that you said earlier you
have a buffet of Shame you could go yeah
I don't have any like deep Dives I was
watching the Clips of the show to get
ready I'm like there's no getting ready
dude you don't need me on this show man
like I was like because like I don't
know I don't even know some of the
people but I'm not it's not like I know
every comedian let's click on whoever
this is like and then when I was eight
years old my veins clapped from heroin
use like what the dude what
oh
when I was eight I was heartbroken
because my friend didn't want to play
pretend spaceship in the yard anymore
you'd be bloody like sucking dick to pay
for food for their younger siblings I'm
like why am I on this show I don't
deserve to be on the show this is for
fun much more outlandish stories than
mine
thank you for the greatest promo
of the show we've had right there
because we're cutting that I got nothing
on these sons of